[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about
psychedelics policy and advocacy we have
Ismaili joining us on the show thanks
for coming on absolutely I'm very happy
to be here super pumped super pumped and
it was awesome meeting both you and
Annie okay Mike margulies a psychedelic
seminars I was such a good show bye you
too and Annie just came on yesterday
you're here today we're really excited
for those that don't know is males
background
he's a JD he had he's in policy and
advocacy council for maps the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies he was also chairing
on the board of directors for students
for sensible drug policy and you can
find maps as link below as well as SS
DPS link below and Izzy's Twitter as
well so this man let's talk about things
from this big history perspective we
find ourselves as stewards of Earth what
is your current take on the state of
humanity I have a few thoughts a few
levels to to the analysis I've got but I
will say that you know using the story
framework we've definitely maybe created
some space between our understanding of
what that role should be and what's
actually going on and I think that that
like gap of or that gap that exists that
unwillingness that a lot of people have
have had toward that role has led to
what feels like to a lot of people and
what seems to me perhaps like a crisis
point of some kind I also see us in this
time of extreme trends extremely rapid
transition but specifically around how
we think about big questions around
power and accountability and I think
that although a lot of people are
thinking about the status of humanity
with respect to how we handle
solving the problems that we see ahead
of us I actually see the status much
more based on how we decide to solve
whatever problems that emerge and I
think looking at that process how we
deal with power and accountability how
we deal with decision-making and
governance
those questions are I think developing
with more attention to detail than I've
seen in a long time and that I think
honestly gives me much more Hope than
just looking at the the status of the
outcomes in general like I think that if
we're judging our species role simply by
what we're currently at it's it could be
very easy to get very daunted very
quickly but I do see people who really
who are willing to step up in
preparation for that shift and that
gives me a lot of hope so I guess to
answer your question the status of our
whole species and this whole process
quite precarious but also quite inspired
and I think that's a good combination
yes yes I really loved how you phrased
it as we are here to be stewards of
Earth and to each other and yet there's
a gap of what's missing from that to be
at its optimal stage and so then it's
kind of like what do we what code do we
need to update so that there's not
anymore yes and psychedelics and
meditation unit feelings of unity and
oneness with each other is seems to be
at in one of if not the greatest
principle of driving us towards that
unity and that wholeness so I'm really
glad that this is what you what you
identify as as as the state okay now on
the journey side of things who are you
how did you become where you're at today
so I am still working on answering this
question for myself but I'm gonna give
you the most updated version that I've
got so I was actually I'm
first-generation Muslim American
multi-religious multi-ethnic child of
immigrants in some ways new to this
continent to this part of the world
in a way that none of my ancestors have
ever been before so in many ways I am
though one of the outcomes one of the
things that happens when we exist in
this hyper connected globalized society
my parents my father came from Pakistan
my mother from Colombia to Fresno
California in 1986 and that's where I
was born where I lived for many years
until I moved up to Berkeley California
to pursue law school but I grew up in
Fresno around a very multicultural
multiracial multi-religious community I
was raised Muslim but around a lot of
people who identified with a lot of
different faiths did a lot of interfaith
activism and like the post 9/11 era as a
teenager and spent a lot of my youth
like really engaging with big questions
around identity mostly focusing on
religious ones but ultimately because of
the way that politics and domestic and
foreign policy shaped around me you know
in the post 9/11 era that rapidly became
an interest in civil rights and civil
liberties and how really the
construction of freedom was provided or
constructed the construction of freedom
was constructed by the US government and
by these entities that were purportedly
you know operating to keep me and my
family safe the what I discovered over
time was that as I kind of really dove
into my own identity as a Muslim
American as a child of immigrants just
someone who experienced a tremendous
amount of privilege going up especially
with respect to education and the
communities that I was a part of but
also a lot of discrimination I started
to recognize that like a lot of these
large questions around politics around
society or in culture were not just
academic ones they were ones I you know
impacted my day-to-day life so over the
course of my undergrad I studied
philosophy and creative writing I really
focused on kind of I did a lot of Speech
and Debate I really focused on trying to
understand the nature of the problems
that I saw us facing which at that time
were really focused on discrimination in
the military industrial complex how we
treat people in prisons etc and that
kind of led to a much more kind of
understanding of how we did that
internally which led to the want drugs
but before getting to that I'll also say
that this is all happening at the same
time but I personally was interacting
with a number of drug using community as
legal and illegal and I think that being
you know 15 16 year old growing up in
Fresno California seeing really the
beginnings of what would eventually
become the overdose crisis in like 2006
to 2010 or so was where I actually like
did a lot of my political education with
respect to drugs like I had an idea and
a construction of how a kind of domestic
foreign policy was handled by the US
government and by other governments but
when it when it you know when it became
super real and super tangible for me and
my community it was on the question of
drugs drug enforcement and that's really
where what led to me becoming interest
in that as a good topic professionally
when I started law school I had two
goals I was like I'm either gonna do
international diplomacy of some kind
where I'm like doing some sort of peace
building work yeah well I'm gonna do one
drugs work and ideally it's gonna be
both at the same time but right now I
decided to focus mostly on my work like
around the war on drugs and around that
particular topic which interestingly
leads to peace building at the same time
yes yeah absolutely
yeah absolutely and it's also cool how
you teach us about your journey it's
starting to piece together for those
that are that have been watching you and
watching the work of maps that people
like you have that right melting pot of
a sort of cultural upgrade where you're
studying multiple religions studying
multiple ways that people interface with
their communities and their families and
so then it gives you in psychedelic as
well and that's a in using versus not
using so then now that you ended up
doing you know going from Fresno to
Berkeley and doing your doing law school
there what was your big these big
milestones for you that you're like okay
drug reform the war on drugs I'm
watching this how can I best be a part
of the reform there are a few big ones
I'll just share like two or three so one
when I was 16 and I had my first
mushroom experience
I think that that was like a major shift
as like a you know teenager in an
uncontrolled context you know like
pre-clinical pre-party whatever I was
just me and some friends and I think as
a teenager who it was fairly depressed
experiencing a lot of anxiety and a lot
of just dissonance from being you know
Muslim in the post 9/11 world in the
United States having that kind of
internal shift from angst to curiosity
which was a major kind of gift I got
from those few experiences and then
flashing forward up to or kind of going
up to when I was actually in law school
my second summer I worked for the ACLU
of Northern California in their San
Francisco office where I focused mostly
on kind of decriminalization related
issues and bail reform and this was
right before the like but there has been
in lately a huge push around in the
criminal justice reform world around
bail reform and looking at prosecutorial
discretion these two major major issues
in criminal justice and I was like
working at the ACLU I spent nine months
there doing a little bit of work around
that and really getting a taste of what
drug policy work looked like because at
that time the ACLU was working on the
Blue Ribbon Commission which is
something they were doing with
lieutenant governor Gavin Newsom at the
time and that was kind of like the one
year long pre preparatory conversation
for the state of California to have
before prop 64 was pulled forward and
passed in 2016 so I was like kind of
involved a bit like the very early
dialog in the state of California around
that and then at the end of that that
time and so I guess in September
September October 2015 I met Natalie
Ginsburg who is the current policy
director at maps and her and I met and
started talking about the intersection
of psychedelic healing trauma and the
war on drugs and we were like finishing
each other since I thought we were like
on it and as soon as that happened we
started scheming up ways to work
together and the way ended up at maps
was actually that I developed and
submitted a fellowship application to
Berkeley law school so they granted me a
public interest fellowship so Berkeley
Law School funded my first year working
with maps they paid for my first
and that's hired me officially after I
did a year-long fellowship there so it
kind of transitioned from criminal
justice very narrowly within the state
of California context but I've obviously
connected to these much larger national
issues and then that kind of evolved
into me realizing you know Natalie and I
realizing that maps was at a position
that was going to be central to this
question of how the legal regulatory
cultural context of the use of
psychedelics would develop and
specifically that questions around these
issues were no longer a theoretical like
we were at a point now at the end of
2015 that the questions are we can work
would becoming basically more and more
tangible and now you know flash for
almost four years later we're at a point
where like we've got a timeline like
this stuff needs to be figured out
within the next few years so like when
we're thinking more tangibly about you
know some of the topics we'll get into
later about like what to do how to build
this system yes I'm a lot of that
involved bringing an understanding of
criminal justice reform and civil rights
and how we relate to psychedelics and
sacred plant medicine practice doesn't
all of these things all of which were
things that I was I had some experience
with at some point and I and it just
kind of worked out where I was like you
know we all realized at the same time
that someone needs to do something and I
was like okay well let's let's see what
we can do together and kind of went from
there even back to what bail reform yeah
even back to this very just simple thing
of when you get jailed for cannabis your
jails absolute Alex and and it's like
how can we help make this process much
more easy and seamless and and not less
friction and all this type of stuff and
so that even all the way back to that
and fast forward like you said for years
and the conversations that you're having
with Natalie about what exactly needs to
be done with this sacred plant medicines
with the actual reforms of legislation
and with countries around the world
totally how can we catalyze the
spiritual transcending that we need to
so much to have to happen
totally and it's cool that you also had
your work with students for sensible
drug policy SSDP it's an international
network of students dedicated to ending
the war on drugs and you gave you you
gave us the example of your work
they cou as well so when you know Rhonda
showed this asset also with with this
was at the United Nations the war on
drugs destroys life so yes so teach us
about you know this sort of part of
things yeah so students for sensible
drug policy was founded 21 I want to say
21 years ago we just had a 20th
anniversary and it was originally a
bunch of students who were organizing
around the idea that if you had a
criminal conviction on your record that
you were not able to receive student
loan grants which meant that people who
had been incarcerated were prevented
from receiving grants or loans from the
federal government in order to attend
school effectively making it impossible
for people who had been incarcerated to
achieve an education and that was kind
of like the central one of the central
organizing issues at that point over
over the last 20 years it's expanded to
include things like Good Samaritan
policies so like when people overdose or
when something goes wrong a university
you know students organize to get
universities to promise that they won't
prosecute people or won't bring in law
enforcement in situations where you know
some some health crisis emerges of
course lots of things around cannabis
legalization and other kinds of
regulatory issues or kind of legal
issues so students for sensible drug
policy has really just been one of the
vehicles through which this particular
population students first in the United
States and now increasingly around the
world
I think we're operating in almost 30
countries now are organizing around but
like I said originally policy is that
mostly impacted students and they are
now expanding beyond that to really to
really look at kind of policies that
affect young people in general and
really trying to make you know although
there's like the actual direct
organizing around the war on drugs
element it's also the case that for many
young people drug is drug-related issues
like the first thing that they care
about or one of the first things that
really is a political issue and from my
perspective as someone who's really
trying to encourage like mass-scale
civil civic engagement to me it doesn't
really matter necessarily what it is
that gets you interested in politics as
long as you're engaging with the system
in some way just to make sure that your
voice is being heard and if that's drugs
then great you know all the better it
was for me like you know if it wasn't
for
it was kind of some kind of simultaneous
if it wasn't for you know the
criminalization of my communities as a
Muslim person that was getting like
surveilled I don't even know if I would
have cared about politics till I was
much older if it wasn't for drugs also
so it was like all these topics were
coming up at the same time when I was a
teenager I didn't actually discover SSDP
till I was in law school
and then I ended up running the chapter
with two other amazing colleagues of
mine Rachel and Ben who were both also
in law school with me at the time and we
basically helped develop the
conversation especially at that time at
UC Berkeley and in California around
equity issues that we'll talk about in a
bit as well but equity issues in
cannabis about like what it means to be
able to make money off of something that
for so long was used to criminalize and
harm people and that was something that
we talked about we did an event about in
like March of 2016
even before prop 64 was passed so really
trying to bring attention to these big
issues that we knew we're gonna come up
and I think we might have been the first
group to do an event about psilocybin
mushrooms at the UC Berkeley law campus
which was something I was really proud
of it we were really proud of and at
that time that was well before we were
think about legalization that was really
just about educating lawyers about like
you know drug policy related issues as a
really just like a dellux weather
organization has really done a lot and
like you know there's what we'll see
more but there's a whole lot let's pull
that one up there's a photo of a bunch
of society yes youth civil society at
the United Nations so this is like a
bunch of this is actually in 2000 I want
to say 2008 so probably just over a year
ago tell me they're in 2018 or 2018 18
this is me in a suit looking I really
Square at the bottom but this is the UN
like there's a whole coalition of young
activists that go to the United Nations
every year and engage with the
Commission on narcotic drugs which is
basically the global cup convention it's
where all the law enforcement agencies
from all over the world gather to
develop to develop a strategy to align
it with with international goals and
yeah there's just a huge group of kind
of like young activists and advocates
that participate in this process by
engaging with that and I'm lucky to
participate in that group through maps
but this is this includes groups like
students for sensible drug policy yoga
youth organize you
youth organized against drug action or
something like that there's a few organs
that are coming from all over sstp
Canada and Australia there's a few works
from all over that are really really
active that do that it's pretty amazing
wow this is so cool learning about all
this from you even at the scale of being
able to come in and talk at the new
United Nations about it you said SSD
peas in 30 I think so something like
that 20 something 20 high number yeah
it's that's also really cool to start
seeing it seep into the sensible
policies now absolutely for drugs
the seep into reform around the world
because like you said a lot of young
people get engaged when they you know
they're maybe they're smoking some
cannabis or whatever it may be when
they're young and all of a sudden their
friend goes to jail for it and they're
like what is this jail for you know or
they or they're trying to have you know
they they feel oneness when they're on
psilocybin or LSD or what-have-you and
then and then all of a sudden they're
going to jail and they're like why is
this thing that's delivering feelings of
oneness also making me go to jail the
system like ya may notice but there's
some sort of dissonance and it's funny
it's like dare so when you a lot of my
generation went through dare yeah we've
got like the the doobies with the big
googly eyes that are like telling you
about how cannabis is like the worst
thing and it's funny because I remember
vividly as soon as young people realized
that the Doobie was lying to them about
how bad weed is they start questioning
what they were what the what the meth
pipe was asking them you know like and
like not to be dramatic but it's true
like once like when the government or
when some sort of any sort of authority
that's supposed to be looking out for
our health and safety lose its its
credibility by lying to the face of
young people about the actual effects of
some of these drugs then there's no real
reason for that young person to continue
to believe that entity for anything much
less other ones that try to issue the
same kind of authority it's a
trust-building thing and like yes if you
can't build trust with young people who
are way smarter and way more thoughtful
and way more critical than you think
they are you know random government
agency or person or teacher whoever it
is then then you're the one that's gonna
get get punked you know cause like
they're smart young people that way I
work with people
surround myself at the community are
absolutely brilliant people who really
care about you man who really care about
what we're doing with each other and
with these substances and and at least
if there was that tiny bit of nuance
there like this catalyzes really
powerful feelings of oneness but at the
same time doing it a lot can potentially
share - yeah like decreases in your
productivity
there was the nuance yeah there wasn't
no it's correct it was all bad yeah the
doobie is gonna kill you yeah no
moderation is key so and there's another
image Ronnie the international drug
policy reform so this is a conference
that brings together people from around
the world who believe that the war on
drugs must end and this is coming up
November 6th through 9th in 2019 in st.
Louis Missouri the international drug
policy reform conference yeah I'm a huge
fan of drug policy Alliance which is the
organization that puts this on this is
like I said like it says a biannual
conference I really appreciate this
particular conference because it's one
of the places where a huge number like
you know twenty five hundred or so 2011
review attendees from literally all over
the world jug who are drug policy actors
from all over the world doing everything
from direct service harm reduction with
IV drug users to people who are thinking
about like psychedelic medical
regulation to people who are thinking
about access to uber an orphan and
Medicaid assist is treatment in prisons
from you know like every single spectrum
you can imagine that involves the war on
drugs being discussed here and I have a
particularly special place in my heart
for it because it's the first place
where I actually got a platform to speak
and it was in 2015 actually I was still
a student I was working with SSDP and
this amazing activist and advocate named
Amanda Ryman who was in the social work
department at Berkeley she was a
professor there she night works for a
company called Flo kana but she was
helping DPA put together she was
actually working at DPA and at that time
as well and she put me on a panel about
I think was called beyond prohibition it
was in 2015 and it was like what does
the future beyond prohibition look like
and it was really special because I was
like the radical youth voice in the
midst of like all these kind of like
older very well published academics who
are talking about drug policy
and that was in 2015 and since then I'd
really like continued to develop that
particular strain of thought focusing on
what do we do when prohibition ends
because so much of the work that's
direct policy when it's a SSDP that
these orders do is about ending the war
on drugs and there's lots to talk about
there there's lots to do there and I
think that there needs to be
simultaneously a good amount of energy
put toward to what the next system is
going to look like and this isn't just
true with drug policy this is true with
energy this is true with healthcare this
true with housing like we need major
paradigm shifts and all these sectors
and I think mental healthcare and how we
deal with consciousness is one of those
places where as we start to dismantle
the limitations the things that we've
been kind of handed maybe as as defaults
which may not be true or omit wane that
may not be the cover the full picture
may not be accurate how to respond to
those with some sort of generative
vision for whatever happens next and I
think that a lot of that visioning
regarding the drug policy movement
happens here I'm really I'm a big fan
I'm really excited for this year yeah
yeah this is a public health a mental
health absolutely wrong the world
integrating trauma building on on these
psychedelic experiences that can
catalyze these feelings of oneness and
also you mentioned as paradigm shifts
and not only the public health its
paradigm shifts and in in what's
happening with with with education in
general with healthcare in general with
restoring humanity in general all these
types of of paradigm shifts and and I'm
also really happy that you know when
when you speak about it you're also
giving us this this insight into how
it's there is some issues that this is
touching people are touching from that
are involved in prisons and jails with
this type of how this reform affects
that or how this reform impacts a trauma
the people experiencing trauma in
psychedelic psychotherapy so there's all
different angles that that this is
around the world what is gonna happen
host the war on drugs ending how do we
integrate that peacefully into the
social fabric and in a way like you said
a cannabis company that's now you know
selling cannabis what about all the
decades of people that that were
involved and blood sweat and tears then
how can we freedom yeah
how can we adequately distribute yeah
the the rewards yeah yeah correct this
is a big big question and it's one that
I think needs to be answered by a
collective and in the collective and
that's actually probably a good place to
start because we're thinking about the
benefits that come out of an industry or
of a movement or of any sort of
organized kind of kind of a collection
of and distribution of resources however
that looks like one of the pieces that
absolutely needs to be considered with
respect to drugs in particular is as you
said really identifying and repairing
the harms from prohibition and there's a
few ways to look at that some of them
include the obvious ones like people
who've been incarcerated and looking at
how much has been lost in communities
and for individual people but of course
for all that also for their whole
communities with respect to that but
there's also kind of a secondary level
of what it means to have perpetuated the
system of criminalizing really behavior
that's entirely about oneself and that
so closely implicates questions around
trauma and mental health care and has
loaded so much stigma into the the kind
of whole field of engaging with one's
own mind in a liberated way so that's
much deeper that's that's much deeper
and much harder to track than how we
have physically restricted people's
Liberty both are critical but if you
look at the scope of time I mean the
Catholic Church was Jenna citing the
indigenous user users of plant medicine
practices in central america 500 years
ago so there is a direct tie between the
genocide of these cultural practices
that empower groups of people to fight
oppression to develop resistance to
develop cultural contexts for use and
accountability in those contexts and
today's system of incarceration there's
a link there well
and that is based in stigma that's based
in racism that's based on these systems
of oppression so when we're looking at
what the harm is like the first step for
me is a clear accountability of what the
harm actually is like we can look at and
I really am so in awe of a lot of the
cannabis activists that are fighting for
equity right now in the industry because
they're looking at they're literally
trying to put a dollar amount the amount
of years people are spending in prison
for nonviolent drug offenses they're
like how do we how does the US
government pay that back like people
talk about reparations for slavery and
reparations for past harm and like a lot
of the time those conversations get
really scaled really quickly and they
frighten a lot of people who don't
understand how to have a conversation
about historical harm and how to make
that difference what's happening now in
the cannabis world and like this is just
one example is actually looking at like
for example and this is it's interesting
because this ties to the question of
bail reform like back to that original
topic we've criminalized poverty for
four decades in this country we've
criminalized not having the money to
post bail which means that there are a
number of people who've paid out a ton
of money to jails and prison systems and
various government systems who are have
done that in a context of unjust laws
that we now know have harmed those
people yeah how do you get those people
that money back it's very how do you get
this because that's quantifiable that's
not like that's not like how did my
generational ancestry no no yeah that's
like and by the way I also think that
there should be reparations for the
ancestral stuff too but putting that
conversation that's a bigger
conversation putting that aside for now
looking very like much around this
particular particular topic it's a very
grounded numeric yeah yeah and it's not
and again it's not like this is not my
idea this is something excuse me this is
not my idea this is something that's
come from like these cannabis activists
that are like how do we repair those
harms very candidly so looking at that
from like a psychedelic perspective
looking at psychedelics and what it
means to not have had access to these
practices it's more than just people
should have access to second psychedelic
therapy legally it's what are the how do
we quantify the mental health impacts of
living in the world that we're currently
living in and how much of that has
impacted by incarceration by the
criminal legal system by all these
things like these are massive massive
massive questions they're not easy ones
but when we're talking about what it
what it means to return or like not even
return to let's say birth or created
just world like all of these historical
elements need to be encountered and
acknowledged before we can actually try
to think about what this new system is
building that we're building is because
if we build that system without an
cutting acknowledging for that that
stuff then we're not actually building
the assistant we're just building on top
of the old one that's not gonna work
someone's gonna try to dismantle that -
it was crazy hearing you speak about
this from a perspective of so
enlightening for me when you when you
speak about it like think about how much
the are in accessibility unaccessible
that we have to the to the substances
the mother earth secretion of these
substances that because we have not had
the right access and and psychotherapy
systems with those that how much has
that caused so much addition unnecessary
mental health issues unnecessary war
unnecessary the the social fabric it has
more tears in it because we didn't do
that I love that take on it because then
you can really start thinking about it
like where did you know where did this
war even come from in the first place
and why I have the elders for thousands
of years been been practicing with this
but all of a sudden in the modern world
that's not it's not allowed our next
images slowly bring us into your you
know your speaking um maps so it's been
three years for you over three years now
with maps the multi-discipline sociation
for psychedelic studies developing
implementing policy and advocacy
strategies to support access to
psychedelics or medical legal and
cultural use and this was after your
conversation with Natalie right there
you guys were like finishing each
other's sentences what you under this is
you speaking in Colombia yeah so this is
actually in Colombia at an event called
semana sequel Kiva psychoactive week
which was organized by this amazing
armor
an organization in Aruba without called
excellent technique a social social
technical action AC ATS and they it was
actually the 10th anniversary and this
organization is actually quite amazing
because they just published with some
other orgs just actually was at this
conference about a year ago we published
a plan like they're you know a plan with
recommendations of how to bring cocaine
entirely out of the underground market
into a legal regulated market at global
market and the you know these are
Colombian activists that are looking at
the kalam the coke problem in cocaine
problem in Colombia they're like this is
our solution it's really really like
huge work that has a you know tremendous
implications on global drug policy I was
there because I was I was getting a
chance to discuss a study that we were
actually looking forward to that we're
just now starting to move forward with
there which kind of ties a lot of the
questions you kind of brought up all
together actually so part of my role at
maps this too as you said like developer
to implement these legal and policy
strategies which is just a fancy way of
saying trying to predict and build
capacity for this post-prohibition world
so on a practical level it means a lot
of different things but that for one
means having a lot of dialogues and
conversations with people from a lot of
different sectors of sectors of society
from the government to various sectors
of the government to professionals in
various sectors to the public to these
various entities so here there was
actually so this is an in Bogota
Colombia this this event it was attended
by a number of members of the Colombian
military and a the Colombian drug policy
kind of administration as well as
members of the Colombian Narcotics
Control Board and of course a lot of
members of civil society and people who
are just interested in drug policy in
general and I was there to talk about
the possibility of mdma-assisted
psychotherapy for PTSD specifically the
possibility of doing a study a phase 2
study in Colombia looking at the
efficacy of mdma-assisted psychotherapy
for PTSD in Colombia and as you know
that's the kind of the flagship project
that maps has been focusing on for the
last decade and a half or so a couple
decades awarded breakthrough status from
the FDA order breakthrough status from
FDA
and a special purpose or special
engagement letter my camera exec what
the term is but we have we've engaged
with FDA have experienced a lot of
support from them that's really going
forward as smoothly as possible we're in
phase 3 right now with the intention of
and and kind of expectation of it
proving MDMA as a for use in therapy for
PTSD by 2021 which is really really
exciting and Rick was also teaching us
on the show about the importance of the
clinical trial design yes and how that
can then be applied to studying all
different other types of psychotherapy
absolutely absolutely so we've actually
were actually adapting the NDA for PTSD
protocol now with cognitive behavioral
therapy and with exposure therapy and
with other two other indications so not
just PTSD but also we've studied social
anxiety for adults with autism we've
said we're developing a protocol right
now around eating disorders end-of-life
anxiety so there's a lot of like ways
that the medical use the medical
therapeutic framework is actually
developing and here we were talking
about doing an MDMA for PTSD open-label
kind of pilot study in Colombia with
people who had experienced PTSD from
different sides of the civil war in
Colombia which was a 50 to long civil
war which was troost two years ago
unfortunately there's complications of
the truce and we'll see if that holds up
a pretty-pretty to 52 years civil war
yeah from with with parties from it was
like the far left Getti the far right
paramilitaries and then the government
and there was a car there was like
ongoing kind of violence and like that
was a that was exacerbated by not even
necessarily caused by but exacerbated by
the cartel violence totally so it's like
it was a whole vortex and that's my
personal like family context like that's
where my mom and her family came from so
I being back in Colombia and 2018 to
talk about the possibility of MDMA for
PTSD research on people who had survived
the civil war that was quite impactful
and that really is an example of like
you know there I was I was there to
describe the study but I wasn't just
describing the city for the public you
know we had members of the Colombian
military and drug control team they're
like we are trying to communicate with
these regulatory bodies with his
government agencies so they understand
that when we're talking about
decriminalization or legalization of
these drugs we're talking about it in a
really intentional context we're talking
about anyway that's really thoughtful
because I don't want
you scare someone who could otherwise be
a supporter by letting them think that
this is not something that people are
really really mindful about and that's
kind of like the core maybe guiding
principle a lot of the work that I do as
a policy advocate at maps a lot of it
really just has to do with helping
people bring more awareness to what they
think they want and help us as a society
develop more robustly the dialogue that
we're having so we can mature into a
mature into the infrastructure that we
need to have so we can actually have
safe and legal access I believe in the
possibility and the importance of like
legal regulated access for a lot of
these substances and I think that if we
just like legalize some stuff tomorrow
some it would be there would be some
major challenges we'd have to bend your
obstacles and challenges we have to deal
with yes so I think part of its not just
about creating the legal framework it's
all about it's also about developing
society and culture into a place where
it's ready to engage with that framework
and that's really the core of a lot of
the work that I'm doing because you gave
this crazy example of Columbia I think
50 years of civil war and also having to
try and deal with cocaine and exactly
you know this is crazy
for that and then you know all all of
like what do we exactly do with you know
in the United States so the next the
next asset shows you guys at the what
the United States Congress and when you
know you can you can teach us about this
I just want to also mention just how
like crazy it is that you know the
United States is having its own issues
with drug policy and drug reform and
reparations and all this stuff then you
have other places like Portugal which
we'll get to in a little bit and what
advances they've made into the
Netherlands etc there's all this crazy
how do you like you said on the
community level on the level yeah well
one of the this is actually a great
segue because one of the ways to do that
I think is to really stay connected with
and in dialogue with the community of
people who are going to be impacted by
policy change so a lot of policy change
happens in like the very heady ivory
tower old tower level because most
people who are involved in policy change
come from very elite circles and it's
kind of like a revolving door of
generations of people who are making
most of the rules most of the time a lot
of that's change with social media and a
lot of interesting shifts toward
populism
and that in general has meant that
people are learning how to develop more
political power and agency in the
current like political context which
includes one that brings in social media
so this is actually great photo because
this is so there's an organization
called a minority cannabis Business
Association and I've participated it in
this they've been in policy summits for
the last four years I've participated I
think three out of four of them were two
out of four of them mostly creating
model language and model ideas for what
policy change at the municipal state and
federal level would look like in a way
that includes equity and justice
provision so like expungement of
offenses by creating a community fund
where the taxes from this strum from
cannabis sales go to so they can benefit
communities that were impacted by the
war on drugs whether or not they have a
dispensary in that community you know
it's like really broad yeah they sing
and of course things like priority
licensing and things along those lines
as well so the minority cannabis
Business Association is really doing a
lot of work to develop the the dialogue
around equity in the cannabis industry
and this is with representative or Elle
blue and hammer from Oregon rep barbara
Lee was also a supporter this is uh kind
of just presenting the model state
legislation and actually preparing for
lobbying on the hill around the states
act and around the marijuana justice Act
and really talking about what does it
mean to include equity at the in the
conversation at the federal legal level
because so far it's all been about like
state patchwork Massachusetts is trying
some stuff Oakland is trying some stuff
SF you know there's a lot of entities
are cities and states that are trying
some equity provisions but its new its
was still wearing how to do it there's a
lot of failure but a lot of progress and
I think that over the next few years
we'll see a really robust conversation
develop around that topic and going back
to your question like how to stay
connected so much of this stuff around
equity a lot of this comes out of having
being in dialogue with communities that
are impacted and so similarly like going
back and forth from like the UN to SSDP
conference to like you know being on the
hill and speaking with reps and doing
all this so much of it is just for me
personally like what am I like doing
here what am I like what's the actual
like outcome I'm
this incredible incredible privilege to
have this amazing education to be in the
room and a lot of these really really
interesting places where all these
cutting edge conversations are happening
I just you know in addition to being as
accountable as I can be to the community
people that I'm working with in my own
personal community the other thing is
how like how do I is ensuring that I
remember that part of the privilege and
part of the opportunity that I have is
to you like
continue to act clearly as a channel for
the people who are most impacted who are
going to be most impacted because I took
because until until you know people like
the ones in this photo are actually
making more decisions what policy looks
like we're gonna keep in the in the
hamster wheel of or not actually it's
like a it's like a combination between a
hamster wheel at will and whack-a-mole I
don't even know what that looks like a
little puppet yeah yeah we're just like
we're like whacking moles that are like
not going anywhere I don't know there's
some metaphor in there somewhere but
it's like we to do a really deep
structural change on an empowerment and
engagement ago that are most disengaged
currently exactly it's really about
people are that can be disengaged
because they're like privileged
Caucasian students on college campuses
who care about drugs no crime right
anything else like fine like let's take
them and like let's get them to care
about this w or it could be people who
have been disenfranchised because
they've been forced to because they were
incarcerated and they're black or brown
and they're in jail and they're also not
accessing so you know there's different
reasons that people don't access the
system and at this point it's like get
people talking about the system because
then at least we have at least once we
have a little bit more clarity on what's
actually there we can have a mature
conversation but what to do next instead
of all of this hysteria yes fear in
offices what did what an interesting way
to plant the seed by saying that and
then all the trying to get in all these
United States states that are going
through the reform process how do you
you know make a make a piece of the tax
revenue go towards a community fund
right these are such cool lines of code
that can get laced in but it requires
people to go out and and speak on this
and get the Congress involved in the
Transformer transformative processes
that are so needed that's so very very
beautifully put what are what are is the
code that we're going to update at post
war on drugs
what are how are we gonna write that
code the next image is with Rick oh yeah
with Rick Doblin where were you guys in
this photo
this is at Washington DC okay this isn't
Washington DC I catharsis that's Ryan
from the zendo that's Rick myself and
actually that's Natalie next to me and
this great strange person with the blue
claw so this is that in Washington DC
right after an event called catharsis on
the mall okay so catharsis on the mall
is a now essentially a regional burn so
it's like in charge of like the bringing
my network and it was um it's not quite
like an official reasonable but it's
basically it's an vigil and occupation a
party a celebration it's a three-day
event that occurs on the Washington Mall
in between the Washington Monument and
the White House like on that in that
regressor area they were doing it's in
2015 like a mini bird look at many brain
literally read a long anybody who
happens right there and it was actually
first done at the first comments that I
was talking about drug policy reform at
the International Forum Carmen's in 2015
focusing on the trauma of the war on
drugs so they brought speakers to talk
about yes people who've been impacted
were on drugs and we're talking like
American people who have been
incarcerated and we're talking about
like moms who lost their children at a
yachty Napa which was like the 52
Mexican kids whose that bus disappeared
you know like like we're talking real
harm real harm and like what that really
looks like and the two Mexican kids yeah
so in 2015 a bus full of 52 Mexican
children was disappeared in ayotzinapa
and the Mexican government essentially
failed to do any sort of investigation
until many many many days later like
over a month later and they find them no
I I actually don't remember honestly
that's how like F table this whole world
is that I can't remember the end of that
drug works not a lot of other um I think
I want to say that they did and I'm
certain it was not a happy ending it was
I'm almost certain that this was like a
horrific situation I'm like I'm
literally apologizing to you and the
audience for not remembering this fact
because it's like it was so tragic and
like it's so tragic that it happened but
at the time like that was really one of
the big issues that was drawing
attention to Mexico's response in the
drug war and how the Mexican government
was responding to very real relations
right so to a woman who had children who
were lost actually came up for that
event but first catharsis and they spoke
it was a vigil it was a vigil for those
who have been lost to the war on drugs
and that has evolved into an event and
every morning after the last day on
Sunday morning after the last day and
they do a big like burn like a temple
burn just like there whatever any met
what people write you know about the war
on drugs or about these different themes
this year the theme is our mothership
you know looking at the earth and our
relationship to the earth but afterward
they do a huge parade we literally do
like a proper parade around like the
whole area with Burning Man art cars and
like that like hundreds of people all
costumed it's like a little bit absurd
it's actually a lot absurd but it's it's
like you know if this is what gets this
particular demographic riled up about
politics then like let's get them
roundabout about about what it is
because it impacts them and impacts
people that are less privileged than
they are and if they're advocating for
people that are less privileged in them
as well as people in their position and
we're you know moving the conversation
in the right direction then like again
I'll take the voices we need them yeah
so that that particular photo wasn't it
was the morning after we had just
literally we had probably I was like a
year or two ago so we had probably just
Trump was in office and we had probably
just maybe maybe yelled a couple things
toward the White House at that point in
time and then continued there and you
know when you're speaking about also on
a on a drug and policy reform level it
also seems as though the there are so
many other pressing variables you've
been speaking about it as huge melting
pot of variables and that's been very
educational one of the pieces that you
know this next image shows us is the
cannabis that you're using currently for
the for running like PTSD for veterans
all different types of psychotherapy but
it's crazy that there's a monopoly on
the cannabis from midsummer me
University of Mississippi yeah I'd be
happy to talk about this for bit so this
is this is the cannabis that's grown by
the it's actually it's grown at the
universe's University of Mississippi but
the it's the National Institute of drug
abuse that runs the lab and yeah so we
do clinical FDA presearch with various
substances including cannabis and one of
the main obstacles that we've had has
actually been to
to get the drug product that we can use
for these trials and we have had to rely
on the source of cannabis that is
created that right now only comes out of
this night a lab there are a lot of
opinions about the use of that cannabis
and like whether or not it's effective
or whether or not it's like the right
product to be using in this context but
regardless we cannot use it for our
phase 3 trials because we cannot we have
to be able to use the same substance in
the phase 3 trials as whatever goes to
get approved and we can't approve night
as experimental cannabis for phase 3 or
FDA won't approve that for phase 3 and
we can't sell it on the market after
approval so right now we're in this kind
of limbo where our clinical research
with cannabis is actually more
challenging than the work we do with
MDMA because meanwhile Israel's all like
yo have 60 cents of gram for some best
oh yes in the world Israel and Canada
and possibly India possibly Colombia
there's a lot of a lot of countries that
are gonna start developing medical
strains of cannabis and extracts and I'm
although there's you know a little bit
of concern about what that like will
practically look like ultimately speak'
means that there will be more medicines
that are created out of the substance
and in what we've been committed to is
actually allowing the the bud to stay
whole and actually doing smoke to
vaporize full plant but to enjoy to get
benefit from what's called the entourage
effect the whole substance yeah and
FDA's never put a smoked product through
it through FDA before so there's a lot
of things that make that challenging
it's quite complicated much red tape can
inhibit some of the global innovations
that want to happens totally and like I
mean these other countries are gonna
just race ahead of the US as far as drug
development and medical development goes
that's just like until the u.s. changes
its policies in that respect and
actually allows licenses to be granted
which the DEA has already permitted
they're just not doing it so as soon as
they actually like you know the the
Attorney General you know bar signs off
on these applications because I'm moving
forward then we'll have potential source
we're working with someone at the
University of Massachusetts at Amherst
who's a cool bagi professor who wants to
grow for research you know it's great
yeah yeah so we're
what happens with that but that is a
that monopoly that government up Leon on
the night of cannabis has happened has
been going on for 50 years I've provide
fewer like zero and I have personally
been working on Oh only for about the
last two and a half so yes this this is
another one of those variables that's
put into the equation not only does it
depend on the government red tape
because they're trying to do it in a
healthy healthy for the people but the
same time where's the sourcing of red
drugs coming from who's got monopolies
on this stuff what are their intentions
you know Albright yeah there's all these
type of things just give you an example
of how much of a vortex this all is so
insist pharmaceuticals INF is in sis
pharmaceuticals which is the primary
manufacture attention though in the
United States you know it's first off
they're currently getting dealing with a
lot of lawsuits from the US government
which I believe is going after them on a
criminal on criminal grounds but they're
being caught up in a lawsuits with in
the same way that Purdue Pharma is for
like basically obfuscating the knowledge
that they had about the addictiveness of
oxycontin yeah you remember all those
like lawsuits that happen to the tobacco
company is that when regulators found
that the tobacco companies knew that
tobacco's cause lung cancer for like ten
years before they told anyone they like
started suing them and pulling millions
and millions and millions others about
these come eve i predict that that's
about that's what's about to happen with
some of these big opioid companies
because there's a lot of evidence that
these opiate companies like actively
marketed to ward doctors actually bribed
doctors actively like did all these
things that made it eat much easier for
problematic for people to develop a huge
ahead but have like proud of Matt
prominent what was up prescribing so
anyway that's all happening in the
opioid world right I'm so glad in you
taught us about that incest pharmacist
pharmaceuticals the maker of fentanyl
just put five hundred thousand dollars
to fight the legalization of adult used
cannabis in Arizona in 2016 I think it
was like the only one that year that
lost but half a million dollars to
fighting it into pharmaceuticals is also
pursuing a contract with the US
government to be the creator of
synthetic THC in cannabis
for drug development so we're talking
like some really really like twisted
stuff right like like we're out here
like this like like scraggly and on top
of it that's like we just want to like
grow cannabis to like so we can have
doobies for veterans and these guys are
like we want to make one one keep it
illegal yeah and we want to develop it
into pharmaceutical drugs that like are
gonna be able to be we want our monopoly
and we want a cork well in this area
that this is a very bad so tying it all
together take it all to what your
earlier and equity and how to be fair
like yeah I really have a question about
how do we capture the progress of
science of research of therapy of all
these things of the money that's gonna
be that's gonna come out of some of
these products like which is for better
or worse inevitable how do we capture
that and how do we put as much of that
into the commons as possible
that's where like community funds come
in that's where redistribution of
healthcare assets comes in like that's
where I think we need to be thinking
about how to actually build
infrastructure this is that's why it's a
literally all together it's like how do
we build infrastructure so when money
starts coming in when these different
paradigms start to shift that we are not
only keeping in mind these most impacted
people but we're actually actively
helping them in a really tangible way I
would love for one day that to see like
the VA or like large state departments
of health or like even better a
universal health care system UHN I'd say
it's cover psychedelic therapy as part
of its treatment plan because it's seen
as that essential for people I don't
think that the cost should be borne by
individual people of course it's gonna
happen of course insurance will have to
cover a certain amount in the u.s. at
least but ultimately we're talking about
like with MDMA a little bit different
because there isn't the same cultural
context it's much more like a
traditional medication we're talking
about something like mushrooms when
you're talking about psilocybin
mushrooms which we have clear evidence
have been used by cultures all over the
world all over the world everywhere it's
like psilocybin as a molecule is kind of
everyone's cultural Patrick that's right
yeah you know we also have clear
evidence that governments all across the
worlds are terribly corrupt interests I
just want to throw you know you asked
how we're gonna get from this point A to
point B and it needs to
a complete collapse of the way we've
been thinking for thousands of years
updating the mental map to the new
mental map couple couple thoughts the
fun for the Commons is fascinating I
agree with that that seems to be one of
the best ways moving forward we talked
about that with artificial intelligence
and robotics well why don't we talk
about what that was I could ever say my
universal basic income already yeah yeah
and universal basic assets it's all
different ways to look at it so how can
ownership of the psychic dogs that
awakened us towards unity also yes
incentivize those that provide a lot of
the innovation the scientists sure but
also the same time distribute us some of
the rewards to especially elders and
those that are most disenfranchised all
that stuff I love that fun for the
Commons notion some of the last thoughts
on the way out I want you to explain to
us about the the the the head in
Portugal his name's yeah ja ja and so
here here you are with Liana with Mike
and who's the fourth Maurice Maurice is
also a filmmaker actually she's a
documentary filmmaker cool so yeah this
is about this because he's it was one of
the ones that helped to bring the
colours Mike wore yeah yeah the complete
war war on drugs in Portugal to an end
and then what but now what's the
question is how did that happen and also
what does it look like now because this
is one of the right principles of yours
is how to make it healthy right so this
is a really illustrative so this is
actually right after boom festival 2018
where a few of us went to go visit well
and just like learn a bit from him about
what happened in Portugal and Portugal
decriminalized all drugs possession and
use of all drugs about 17 years ago and
instituted at the same time a public
health framework that allowed people to
get access to treatment and other kinds
of resources theirs so Portugal has now
been operating in a decriminalized
public health focused framework for
about 15 years and draw was one of the
people that was instrumental in making
that happen so we went to go meet with
him and to just get an idea of where
Portugal's at now 15 years later and
what to do next because whether or not
Portugal style decriminalization is the
best model for everywhere remains to be
seen that's gonna be a play that's gonna
be a question that I think is going to
be dependent on a lot of different
factors but some of the basic premises
that are kind of illustrated here in
that system are really helpful so one of
those is its complete reduction or
elimination of criminal penalties for
the use of possession of drugs so that
means that people do not get car
serrated and like the ideal situation
they're not and they're not really
engaging with the criminal legal system
at all if there is simply like using
possession or possessing the substances
generally speaking there's really low
levels of enforcement it's not perfect
if there's definitely some like bias as
there is in pretty much any policing
system especially on poverty so it's
certainly the case that there's more
kind of there that there are structural
kind of socio-economic issues that are
also at play there but from a structural
perspective the reality is that because
they've decriminalize because they've
been to the simultaneous pot public
health framework they're looking at a
massive reduction in hiv/aids infections
overdoses people who are dealing with
really chaotic drug use because they
have some sort of like they have some
sort of infrastructure that allows
people who are experiencing having
challenging experience with which to
actually be responded to with care with
like social workers or therapist I don't
we know like I said it's successful in
some aspects and less so in others but
ultimately it's a model where we can
look at what other other pair
other paradigms of prohibition or non
prohibition would look like so kind of
like just to bring it all together you
know thinking about the future so much
of that begins with making sure that
people are not being criminalized for
their for what they put into their own
bodies like right now like I can drink
bleach and no one's gonna stop me like I
can like show up to a hospital like
aren't bleach and like they're gonna
whatever they're gonna like pump my
stomach and try to save my life right
like I can give you a poisonous mushroom
you could pick a poisonous mushroom and
eat it and die like that's not illegal
me picking a mushroom like that's
growing naturally in the for in the in a
park-like in the state of Oregon they
said of Washington like could get a gun
pointed at me and gave me five years
right that's happening to T'Pol Corvette
who's fighting a case in the state of
Washington right now so like there are
there are ways to start that process to
make it you know more like even if you
don't fully shift into a public health
framework I would say Lee
compassionate less punitive framework at
least and Portugal's like again not
ideal but like a good place to start
with like what that could look like and
there's other countries Spain has fully
decriminalized her that has
decriminalize drugs Czech Republic as
well there's a few other contexts in
different countries like Colombia has
decriminalized personally use quite a
bit but I think as far as the US goes
like we are so reliant kind of our whole
criminal legal system is so reliant on
incarcerating you know encouragement or
excuse me the so reliant on incarcerated
people who've committed nonviolent
crimes that we have this huge huge huge
huge of a population of people who are
in prison yeah many of which were just
poor who can't afford their bail many of
which who have literally just possessed
something that was illegal and you know
like this comes back to like what does
it mean to reckon with that reality to
acknowledge that reality and to think
about that reality when we're doing the
fun stuff which is creating the new
world like you said earlier yes yes yeah
we said collapse the whole thing
absolutely yes our human element did you
don't need to die go away what's the new
map the new code one at one of the
things that you you know you're giving
us this really interesting example
there's places in in around the world
where elders are using the psychedelic
substances every single day with
different people that are coming in it
there's another place in the world where
you pick a mushroom in a part and you
get a gun pointed at you and you know
for five years and there's other places
these are all basically permutations
they're little experiments happening
Portugal that Spain etc these little
experiments and so we want to know what
is the best code that maximizes our own
psychotherapeutic processes of
integrating traumas and for moving
forward as one as a planet and also what
is most equitable for those that are
disenfranchised for reparations of the
distributing the monetary and the sort
sort of commons this has been such a
fascinating conversation and synthesis
is he thank you so much absolutely I
want I want you to answer a couple
questions that we usually ask our guests
on their way out of that so the first
question that we like asking our guests
is are we alone in the cosmos whoo I
love that question
no absolutely not I also depends on what
you mean by a loan and what you mean by
the Kosmos but no I don't think we're
low in the Kosmos I think that there are
definitely other entities whether or not
their physical material ones that we can
interact with or ones that exist
entirely on energetic or spiritual
planes I'm not sure but I'm very sure
that we are not alone here
I don't feel will have to spend more of
the time on the next episode talking
about those energetic and spiritual yes
yes okay the next question is are we in
a simulation oh this is oh yeah this one
oh god you know I go back and forth on
this but I don't think so I don't think
so because you know going to even your
question earlier like what is the ideal
framework I at this point I still
believe that it doesn't exist I still
believe that we're coding as we go that
doesn't mean it's not a simulation but
that means that at the very least that
there's some sort of interactivity and
that's enough of an answer to that
question that for me to be satisfied
yeah yeah yeah okay our last question is
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world
such a good question what is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world is not a
thing
so I just learned that when you grow a
plant especially a fruiting plant in
your proximity that over time the plant
starts to read your DNA just by being in
proximity like the plant plants adjusts
like these plants have started to learn
about interviewing skills and I hope
some technical direction I certainly
hope so
but fruiting plants they start to
develop trackers to understand the DNA
of the people around them and over time
they actually start to create more of
the nutrients that the person whose DNA
or that the DNA of the picking up live
is missing so plants over time develop a
symbiotic relationship with the people
that are growing them and over time when
a person grows like a lemon tree those
lemons are over time going to be
perfectly suited to this person's DNA
just by being in proximity with them
interesting and that has to do with a
lot of different factors but plants are
able to kind of like show up for us when
we don't even know that we need that
kind of nutritional support and I think
that's really really beautiful I don't
know if it's the most beautiful thing in
the world but I think the ability of
like nature and humans and each other to
really show up in the face of scarcity
and harm and fear and like something
missing that gap that we're talking
about they're very beginning this
conversation and the willingness of not
just people but of nature of the
universe of maybe the simulation to fill
that gap you know maybe not as fast as
we would like it to happen but at some
point there's something really beautiful
about like the ultimate unity of that
correct the ultimate balance yes yes ah
thank you so much as well thank you
forgot to the shows have been such a
pleasure absolutely you're teaching us
about all your work I'm so grateful
thank you for the opportunity to speak
also you asked great questions this this
is a blast of unity - thank you - you -
you think you shout out to round Boggis
for producing and directing I love very
much
thank you think you're so glad to hear
that we'll have to do a little like maps
roundtable - maybe we get Liana and Mike
Maltese or something here that would be
a lot of fun we can talk about this and
also just on a psychedelics policy and
advocacy level it's time to distribute
these thoughts across the world faster
in our communities for everyone that
tuned into the conversation thank you so
much get talking in your communities
comment below with what your thoughts
were on the episode share share share
more of the conversations about this
around the world and your families at
work online
let's get sharing and talking about this
more go help maps below Maps org the
link is below support map support SSDP
as well the stands for sensible drug
policy their links are below follow easy
on twitter as well as link is below
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in simulations links
are below support us help us grow help
us prosper please we would love to help
you out greatly and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world let's update this code
together I love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace
[Music]
[Music]